-(cheering and applause)
-Welcome back!
Now, a writer famously said
a woman needs a room of
one's own to tell her stories.
It was either
novelist Virginia Woolf
or Law & Order's Dick Wolf.
I don't remember.
But, uh, either way,
Nightly Show's own Holly Walker
took it to mean she needed her
own segment to talk about women
and stuff. So here it is.
-♪ ♪
-(birds chirping)
Hi.
Welcome to my lady time.
It's a special time,
usually once a month.
Sometimes more often.
And sometimes
when I'm wearing white pants.
Tonight I'm in the tub.
Why? To talk about something
that's even dirtier
than me. New Jersey.
REPORTER: New Jersey Democratic
assemblyman Tim Eustace wants
to add menstrual cramps to
the list of ailments approved
for medical marijuana.
(cheering and applause)
(chuckling)
Wow.
Looks like those marijuana
restrictions are really...
cramping their style.
♪ Yeah... ♪
Ah.
(chuckles)
Ladies, we all know
why it'd be great
to hotbox our hot box
once a month.
But play the clip anyway.
Rather than giving women opioids
or painkillers,
which is the usual treatment,
uh,
this would be a-a less harmful,
less addictive drug.
That's right.
Some of us are taking opioids
and painkillers every month.
I know what you're saying.
What are we, NFL players?
(chuckling)
(cheering and applause)
Mmm. Mmm, that's good.
It is a little crazy.
Especially because in 2014,
opioid overdoses
caused more than 14,000 deaths.
The only women left living large
from that
are the CEOS
of big pharma companies.
Oh, wait.
Big pharma doesn't have
female CEOs.
(sighs)
Damn.
Another joke foiled
by systemic sexism.
(cheering and applause)
Mmm.
Mmm, that's good.
Mmm...
So why do lawmakers have a...
have to write a special
exemption for menstrual cramps?
It all comes down to one narc.
Governor Christie
has long opposed the use
of medical marijuana.
That's right. Governor Christie
hates medical marijuana
almost as much as
he hates governing New Jersey.
(cheering and applause)
Oh, this?
(chuckles)
The trick is to stay ahead
of the pain.
Cut it off
before it gets too bad.
(chuckles)
Bye-bye, cramps.
Hello, blackouts.
(chuckles)
Mmm.
So if you are in pain,
how can you get pot right now?
Right now in the state,
a doctor must prove a patient
has a debilitating medical
condition with chronic pain.
Excuse me?
What's more chronic than a pain
that comes every (bleep) month?
-(cheering and applause)
-Ugh!
But Chris Christie would rather
I take traditional medicine.
(chuckles)
Don't worry,
I'm not operating
heavy machinery.
For another hour.
(laughing)
Mmm.
But the best part
about the celebrity...
the best part about...
the best part about this
is the celebrity
who inspired the legislation.
Lawmakers noted
Whoopi Goldberg's collaboration
with the maker
of organic marijuana edibles
designed, in part,
to ease cramps.
That's right!
Whoopi Goldberg
is selling pot-infused creams,
chocolates, and bath salts!
(cheering and applause)
(chuckles)
Good on you, Whoopi!
Way to act, sister!
(laughing)
Get it?
Uh, Sister Act.
(laughs)
And-and she collaborated
with another woman.
That makes it a Sister Act 2.
(laughing)
I bet those creams are
how Stella got her groove back.
(laughing)
-(sighs) The Color Purple.
-Uh, Holly, Holly.
Holly, um, I really apologize.
I mean, I know this is your
segment, but, um, are you okay?
Oh, yeah. I am feeling
much better, thank you.
But you know what?
I am getting a little hungry.
-WILMORE: All right.
-(laughter)
I think I'm gonna make myself
a snack.
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
no, no, no, no! Holly!
Holly, stop.
That's dangerous, Holly.
Don't do that.
That's dangerous. Don't.
Yeah, not any more dangerous
than this (bleep).
-(laughter)
-WILMORE: No, no.
(applause and cheering)
Well, let's call it a tie, okay?
I hope my lady time was
as good for me as it was for me.
-(laughter)
-See you next time.
(applause and cheering)
No, Holly, wait!
-Ugh. We'll be right back.
-(applause and cheering)